[Music]
on this tuesday night the u.s president
calls white supremacy a poison joe biden
visits buffalo and condemns those who
spread racist hate we have a problem
with domestic terror it's real the
pressure he's facing to do more we
deserve more than abortion and free food
coupons every 30 days exchanging russian
prisoners of war for ukrainian soldiers
the rationale and the resistance to the
plan magic mushrooms as medication it's
been a real game changer for me the push
to make the prescription more accessible
and the future king and his wife in
canada and they're gonna drag you back
to school who are they meeting and how
are they being received
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
america's president once again acting as
consoler in chief calling for change
after another mass shooting president
joe biden and his wife jill visited the
scene in buffalo where 10 black
americans were murdered while grocery
shopping and they met family members who
are deep in mourning white supremacy
biden said is a poison
in america evil will not win i promise
you
hate will not prevail
and white supremacy will not have the
last word
good evening and thanks for joining us
no american president has spelled it out
so clearly president biden said
americans must reject the racist
so-called great replacement theory the
idea that white americans are
deliberately being replaced by
non-whites it's a lie that's believed to
have motivated the accused gunman in
buffalo and it's a lie spread by some
politicians and talk show hosts in the
u.s who biden said today spread it for
power political gain and for profit our
coverage tonight begins with jackson
prescott in buffalo
confronting this american tragedy the
u.s president called out the hate that
targeted east buffalo and has taken root
across the country white supremacy is a
poison
it's a poison
running through it really is
running through our body politic and
it's been allowed to fester and grow
right in front of our eyes
no more
i mean no more
after meeting privately with families of
the victims the president became
emotional while eulogizing the 10 people
killed by a white supremacist
people like 53 year old andre mcneil
went to buy his three-year-old son a
birthday cake
a son selling a birthday
asking where's daddy
the shooting exposed the growing threat
of domestic terrorism in the u.s and the
increasing number of hate crimes fueled
by right-wing conspiracy theories about
racial replacement amplified and
mainstreamed by cable news social media
and politicians
and i condemn those
who spread the lie for power
political gain
and for profit biden stopped short of
making specific promises he called on
congress to act on gun control and
online radicalization
part of what the country has to do is
look in the mirror
and face the reality
we have a problem with domestic terror
it's real
as the president and his motorcade
passed through this shattered community
residents wondered what good words are
if they don't bring action to stop the
viral spread of hate and we being hunted
down like animals in the streets
don't just promise us things you
promised us things before you never made
it happen few believe this will be the
last attack at the hands of a white
supremacist they can only hope their
warnings about the price of inaction are
heard
you find this kind of hate and jealousy
was taught
to innocent kids growing up
and then with the rage
they tend to act on it
and that's the result
tonight the community in buffalo is
taking action to support the victims
families with their most immediate needs
a vigil is underway this evening outside
the tops supermarket donations of food
and clothing and money are also being
accepted that money critical for
memorial services which are expected to
begin this weekend donna all right
jackson proskow in buffalo tonight
thanks words matter and there have been
calls to stop the amplification of the
great replacement theory including a
plea to fox news and one of its hosts
tucker carlson in a letter to fox u.s
senator chuck schumer writes this
pernicious theory which has no basis in
fact has been injected into the
mainstream thanks in large part to a
dangerous level of amplification by your
network and its anchors citing a new
york times investigation schumer
specifically calls out tucker carlson
saying the host amplified this dangerous
and unfounded theory in more than 400
episodes of his show the murdoch family
which owns fox news has staunchly backed
carlson who hosts the highest rated
program in cable news let's go back to
buffalo now and sean o'shea sean
president biden is the only american
president i can recall who has so
clearly condemned white supremacy in the
u.s and those who spread it but people
in buffalo of course are living with the
consequences of it are they consoled by
the president
i think many were today you're talking
about living with the consequences where
we are right now is what jackson was
talking about a moment ago
giving away food giving away clothing
here
important because that top supermarket
behind me the one that was the site of
this mass shooting has been closed since
then and likely will close for a long
time president biden was welcomed here
this morning a lot of people were
grateful that he came to buffalo to
personally deliver condolences on behalf
of the country that was important and
generally well received but not by
everybody you know i was in a an area
here just a few meters from where we're
standing right now uh just after he
spoke and a large group of people were
loudly talking about how words are one
thing but actions are actually more
important saying that president biden
and the u.s government hasn't done
enough for the black community here's a
little bit of what we
heard the fact that he would come to
this community after we just watched on
video 10 of our elders get murdered shot
down and the only thing you came was to
ask them to give up their guns we
deserve reparations we deserve the same
thing that they have given every other
community
john what information is surfacing about
the 18 year old accused gunman
well it's it's disturbing donna we knew
earlier that there was a manifesto that
he had planned to
come here and target an area where there
was a high percentage of of blacks we
also found out that when he was in high
school
he responded to a a question in a class
an online posting that said that what
did he want to do when he retired that
he wanted to go and use the term
murder-suicide he later uh considered
that and said that was a joke he we also
found out that he was in the hospital
for a psychiatric examination uh
following that
he was allowed of course out he was
allowed to purchase a weapon he had a
bushmaster xm15 rifle legally obtained
although the magazines that were
attached to it were not illegal in the
state of new york so the dribs and drabs
of
[Music]
the suspect are are starting to come out
those details uh concerning to people
especially here who really told me over
the last three days that i've been here
that they feel so hurt so bad because
somebody came from outside the community
and did this to them donna
sean o'shea in buffalo new york thank
you
to ukraine now where one of the war's
lengthiest battles seems to have come to
an end hundreds of troops who have spent
more than two months holed up underneath
mariupol's azostal steel plant have now
emerged those men are now being held in
russian-controlled areas of ukraine and
as redmond shannon reports their fate is
uncertain
surrender is not a word ukraine wants to
use but that is exactly how the kremlin
is framing what's unfolding at
mariupol's as of style steel works
after 82 days of russian bombardment
more than 260 ukrainians have clambered
or been carried out of the compound to
hand themselves over to russia
moscow says more than 50 are being
treated for serious injuries some of
their wives claimed the men were close
to running out of water but the timing
of this extraction could suit both sides
i think the russians simply didn't want
to tie up any more scarce assets in this
particular fight and just simply decided
to cut their losses let the ukrainians
go in return for being able to redeploy
their soldiers
ukraine's president vladimir zelinsky
says the soldiers will eventually be
exchanged for russian prisoners of war
but in russia's parliament this
ukrainian-born member argued for a law
to prevent the swap of what he calls
nazis a reference to azov battalion born
of ultra nationalist roots now part of
ukraine's national guard its wolf's
angel emblem also linked to neo-nazism
russia has used azov's history to paint
the entire ukrainian government as a
fascist regime even though far-right
parties failed to elect any lawmakers in
ukraine's last election
this woman says her husband remains
inside the steel works and worries
russia will not go through with a
prisoner swap
it's not clear how many soldiers like
her husband remain inside the plant now
but it is clear that once they're
removed russia will finally have full
control over the sea of azov coastline
completing the strategically important
land bridge between annexed crimea and
the contested donbass redmond shannon
global news london
if you drive a vehicle you know the
price of gas is still rising according
to natural resources canada the average
price of a liter of regular gas in
canada has hit a record two dollars and
six cents people in vancouver pay
roughly two dollars and 30 cents a liter
at the start of russia's invasion of
ukraine in late february the average
cost was
1.56 cents
alberta premier jason kenney and the
federal natural resources minister
jonathan wilkinson appeared before a u.s
senate committee in washington today
kenny pitched alberta as a trustworthy
source of energy for the u.s and pitched
building another pipeline
alberta will be able to increase our
crude exports to the us
by upwards of a million barrels a day
over the next couple of years but with
political will from washington we could
also get another major pipeline built
that would forever allow the united
states to free itself from imports from
hostile regimes
the expressed frustration the us has
turned elsewhere for oil to countries
like venezuela and saudi arabia kenny
also criticized president biden's
administration for killing the keystone
xl pipeline project the democratic chair
of the committee said he didn't invite
kenny there to relitigate the past
federal national resources minister
jonathan wilkinson also appeared and
urged senators to embrace the idea of
what he called a canada u.s energy
powerhouse and he warned of narrowly
focusing on fossil fuels and hindering
both countries climate goals
the battle for ballots in ontario coming
up what the liberals in the ndp are
trying to prevent on election night plus
the discoveries made deep underground at
the u.s mexico border and the queen's
surprise appearance
ontario's political party leaders faced
off in a final debate ahead of next
month's provincial election on the
agenda the economy education and doug
ford's handling of the pandemic
mr dalduca for two and a half years
literally 24 7
i was working on this pandemic mr ford
respectfully mr ford mr ford
respectfully this is the job that you
signed up for four years ago
our eric sorenson takes a deeper look at
last night's debate and how the campaign
is unfolding
a little spray paint a catchphrase and a
message that government in ontario is
working just fine no change is needed
collaboration with the 444
municipalities which you've had the 12
other premiers the federal government
we've all worked so well together
premier doug ford came under fire in
last night's debate the people of
ontario are fed up with your slogans and
your empty words mr ford took six
thousand dollars out of minimum wage
workers pockets but is the election's
final face-to-face confrontation can the
opposition alter the course of a
campaign for an electorate that doesn't
seem to be itching for change it's up to
each of us to roll up our sleeves and
get it done his thing about getting it
done and kind of steady as she goes is
sort of the it's a good match for the
public mood they're not in in the mood
right now for a significant disruption
polling from ipsos and others puts the
pc's popularity not far below election
night 2018 which gave the party a
resounding majority of 76 seats the race
for second appears to be where the
action is polls suggest the ndp has
fallen back to the mid-20s from 33 in
2018 while the liberals are climbing
from their historic low beneath 20
percent in the last election it suggests
a big fight for the ndp to hold enough
seats to remain official opposition with
the liberals trying to catch up from
just seven seats all the while the
greens trying to increase their share of
the vote you left a wreck behind you it
explains in part the heated exchanges
between the two party leaders who if
they can't win are desperate not to
finish third you only retained seven
seats and that's because you
disappointed ontarians respectfully miss
horvath every time you attack me as
you've done for a year doug ford smiles
add to that the green party mr ford
have you talked to a nurse lately and
progressive parties may well get over 60
percent of the votes cast on election
night but if it splits a little too
evenly among the three parties doug
ford's conservatives may not only win
but possibly retain their majority with
less than 40 percent of the vote eric
sorensen global news toronto
ahead using psychedelics to treat
canadians mental health
this is a look inside what u.s
authorities say is a sophisticated drug
smuggling tunnel it's about six stories
below the u.s mexico border and runs
more than 500 meters from tijuana mexico
to a warehouse in san diego california
it's fitted with rail tracks lights
ventilation systems and as reinforced
walls the tunnel was discovered as part
of a 25 million dollar drug bust six
california residents have been charged
and could face life in prison
major medical milestone in quebec health
canada has authorized a patient in that
province to be treated for depression
using psilocybin it's the psychedelic
substance in magic mushrooms the drug is
still illegal in canada but it's being
studied for use in mental health and can
be used medically in special
circumstances dan spector explains
magic mushrooms as medicine the idea may
seem a little different but it's hard
for thomas hartle to overstate the
impact they've had on his life it's just
night and day hartle has stage four
colon cancer his mind used to be
consumed by thoughts about how he was
going to die and who would be there for
his two kids but since he began
psilocybin therapy everything changed it
gave me a different perspective
on the idea of dying hardel was one of
the first canadians legally allowed to
access the treatment psilocybin is the
active ingredient in the psychedelic
drug commonly known as magic mushrooms
those remain illegal in canada but
patients who have exhausted other
options for mental health conditions
like depression or post-traumatic stress
are now being given special access to
prescribed therapy almost a decade after
the program was abolished under the
harper government we're at the beginning
of something very
very very exciting with canada and
health canada
dr andrew bouin just successfully
advocated for quebec's first ever
psilocybin therapy patient under the
guidance of two therapists and a nursing
team that person will take the drug to
battle depression that wasn't responding
to conventional treatment i see this
substance as
a colleague mindset a lubricant to
psychotherapy mushrooms can rewire
pathways in the brain enhancing our
ability to reorganize thought patterns
to help deal with anxiety depression and
trauma
psilocybin changes the way that you
think about things after years of stigma
mushrooms are gaining more and more
medical credibility
i think we
we shouldn't have to wait for
someone to be treatment resistant
depressed or treatment resistant
post-traumatic stress disorder in order
to get access to these treatments
toronto psychologist dr dominique
morissano is organizing an international
summit on psychedelics next week as
calls grow for greater access she thinks
it's time to have a conversation we need
to know that they work across a number
of different age groups
you know
and
people from diverse backgrounds to
hardle the benefits can't be ignored
it's something that has been a real gift
to to be able to spend this with my
family i would like other people to have
that too
a new treatment and maybe a new way of
prescriptive thinking too dan specter
global news montreal
i'm ross lord in st john's newfoundland
and labrador where truth and
reconciliation is a prominent theme for
the royal visit of prince charles and
camilla the story coming up on global
national
she made it queen elizabeth was well
enough to attend the official opening of
a new rail line named in her honor the
96 year old who used a walking stick was
shown how to use the ticket machine for
the elizabeth line she's not attended
some public events in recent months
because of what the palace calls
mobility problems but she has been out
at two in the last three days and it's
hoped she's well enough for her platinum
jubilee celebrations in early june
to mark her 70 years as monarch the heir
to the throne prince charles and his
wife camilla have begun a three-day
visit to canada the couple arrived in
ottawa tonight where they will be until
thursday their first stop today was in
st john's where prince charles talked
about indigenous reconciliation as ross
lord reports it's expected to be on the
minds of many during this visit
those who care about the monarchy still
care a lot especially when it comes to
seeing the prince who will likely soon
be king his time is due for king so
i'm excited for him for to be to take
the role to share in the crown even
though time has moved on and i do have
my doubts about the future of this
monarchy there is a connection i'm here
today just to see a future king prime
minister justin trudeau led the welcome
to newfoundland and labrador for prince
charles and his wife camilla for a visit
that included traditional ceremonies and
something new
a somber reflection at a heart garden
created to honor indigenous children who
died at residential schools and to
recognize survivors
creator
we greet you this day
and we ask for your guidance
i have greatly appreciated the
opportunity to discuss with the governor
general the vital process of
reconciliation in this country
not
a one-off act of course
but an ongoing commitment to healing
respect
and understanding charles and camilla
didn't have time for everyone like this
migma woman who identifies herself as
grandmother salmon she's been tying
small squares to this fence ever since
the first discovery of the mass graves
of indigenous children one year ago what
would i like for them to know
come over
i'll give them a tie to put on
i'll smudge them
canada's faith in the royal family isn't
what it used to be a public opinion poll
released last month suggests 51 percent
of canadians want to sever ties with the
monarchy even though most have
continuing affection for the queen
in fact queen elizabeth's 70 years on
the throne known as the platinum jubilee
is the reason for this royal tour
[Music]
we are deeply grateful
for your warm welcome
which we will carry with us throughout
this entire tour
merci
thank you
charles and camilla's three-day canadian
tour includes stops in ottawa and the
northwest territories as they blend
historic gestures with contemporary
concerns
ross lord global news st johns
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's year
canada is east braintree manitoba
southeast of winnipeg we'd love to see
your canada please email it to viewers
at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
you